-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great crowd.
Well, guys, we are just one week
away from Halloween.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
But I saw that, due
to a global cocoa shortage,
chocolate is going to be way
more expensive.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yes, the price of chocolate
has gotten so out of hand
that people can only
afford M or M.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
You know,
chocolate's gotten pricey
when you see a guy grating
a Snickers bar
over a kid's Halloween bucket.
"All right, everyone --
everyone gets one dusting."
Right now, the circus peanut's
like, "Well, well, well.
Look who came crawling back."
[ Laughter ]
"Circus peanuts.
Very available."
Yep.
Chocolate is more expensive.
However, if you hand
out raisins instead,
the damage to your house
will cost way more, so...
[ Laughter ]
Well, some big
political news.
This morning, House Republicans
nominated Minnesota
Congressman Tom Emmer to be
their next speaker of the House,
and a few hours later,
he dropped out of the race
because he couldn't
get the votes.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. This morning, Emmer ordered
a thousand business cards,
and this afternoon,
his assistant was like,
"I'm going to go ahead
and cancel that order."
[ Laughter ]
We should've known this guy
was not going
to be speaker of the House.
This is an actual clip from
a congressional hearing in 2021.
Look at this.
This is real.
-Today's gig economy sprung out
from the last recession.
It offers a job
to anyone who wants one.
-I'm sorry. Mr. Emmer?
-Yes?
-Are you okay?
-I am.
[ Laughter ]
-You're upside down, Tom.
-Yeah, yeah.
"You're upside down, Tom."
Guys, I heard that Republicans
held a closed-door meeting
about the House speaker job,
and they blasted white noise
outside the door
so that reporters
wouldn't be able to hear
anything from the hall.
Yeah, well, anyway, we got
a clip of the white noise.
-Really?
-Yeah. Check this out.
-I was raised in a small town
in southern Indiana,
in a big family with a cornfield
in the backyard.
[ Applause ]
-It's the only way
I can sleep at night.
Yeah.
Yeah, after 21 days,
Congress still doesn't have
a speaker of the House.
They picked another
new nominee today,
but then he quickly dropped out.
It can be a little confusing,
so let's break it down
as simply as we can.
It's time for
"The News in Pictures."
-♪ The News in Pictures ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, it's been three weeks
since the House had a speaker,
and lawmakers are
absolutely furious.
They were at a moment where
the entire Republican Party
seems to be having
an identity crisis,
and it's left
the House of Representatives
dangling on the edge.
[ Laughter ]
Speaker is an important job.
You're basically
the star quarterback,
not just some
Dallas Cowboys cheerleader.
[ Laughter ]
But trying to elect
a new one
has left experienced politicians
completely frozen.
All the choices feel
about the same,
like some generic white guy
made by A.I.
But this isn't what Americans
want to focus on right now.
It's Halloween. It's a time for
giant pumpkins, scary skeletons,
and pretending to be
someone you're not.
So hopefully they figure
this out soon
because the whole thing
is getting super old.
This has been
"The News in Pictures."
-♪ The News in Pictures ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Well, yesterday former
president Trump
held a campaign rally
in New Hampshire,
and at one point
during his speech,
he made a pretty
cool discovery.
-Watch this.
-Come for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know how you spell us,
right?
You spell us U-S.
I just picked that up.
Has anyone ever thought
of that be--
I just picked that up.
Couple of days,
I'm reading, and it said "us,"
and I said, "You know,
if you think about it,
'us' equals 'U.S.'"
[ Laughter ]
-I'm giving you all
a few seconds to process that
so we can...
[ Laughter ]
"Us" is "U.S."
Oh, yeah.
It's gonna be a pretty
interesting
presidential library.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ] The wheels on the
B-U-S go round and round.
[ Laughter ]
Round and round.
The wheels on the B-U-S
go round and round.
Swish, swish, swish.
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice] It's weird
when you know
all the four-letter words,
but not the two-letter ones,
you know?
Speaking of Trump, today,
he attended his civil-fraud
trial in New York City
to watch his former lawyer,
Michael Cohen,
testify against him.
And it was the first time that
they'd been in the same room
in five years.
-Ooh.
-Damn, only five more years,
then he would have broken
Melania's record.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it was the showdown
everyone's been waiting for.
Even the judge was like,
"Ooh, this is getting juicy."
[ Laughter ]
Trump couldn't believe
Cohen turned on him.
He was like, "Besides being the
reason you went to jail,
what did I ever do to you?"
You could tell Trump
was furious at Cohen.
He was like, "I'm not even
gonna tell you about
the U.S./us thing that I found."
[ Laughter ]
"You're not worth it."
-Well, tonight,
President Biden,
welcomed Australian
Prime Minister Anthony Albanese
to the White House,
and there was a bit
of a mix-up at first.
But here, check out this video.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's interesting.
"Oh, no."
Yeah.
Well, some news from overseas.
There are some reports
going around that Vladimir Putin
recently had a heart attack,
but today the Kremlin
denied the claims.
It was tough for medics
because the defibrillator
paddles kept slipping off
his oiled up chest.
[ Laughter ]
After the reports,
people accused the Kremlin
of using a Putin body double.
-Huh.
-And Putin said,
[ Southern accent ]
"Now y'all hang on just a sec--"
[ Clears throat ]
[ Russian accent ] I mean,
please hang on.
This is misunderstanding."
[ Laughter ]
Some sports news.
Guys, the new NBA season
tipped off tonight.
And --
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The new NBA season
tipped off tonight with 30 teams
competing for a championship.
We thought we'd welcome
the new season
with a song about the team logo.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ The New York Knicks
have a basketball ♪
♪ The Toronto Raptors
♪ The Miami Heat
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Phoenix Suns
has a basketball ♪
♪ Well, the Indiana Pacers
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Brooklyn Nets
♪ The Orlando Magic
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
have a... ♪
Okay, let's move on.
♪ The Dallas Mavericks
have a basketball ♪
♪ Well, the Utah Jazz,
they have a basketball ♪
♪ Well, the Detroit Pistons
have a basketball ♪
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
ha-- ♪
Oh, geez.
Not this again.
Let's circle back.
♪ The Timberwolves
have a basketball ♪
♪ Well, the L.A. Clippers
♪ And the Portland Trail Blazers
have a -- ♪
Oh, God.
Okay. You know,
let's just figure this out.
♪ It's a real bad drawing
of a candy cane ♪
♪ It's a comma and apostrophe
doing a thing ♪
♪ It's Picasso's version
of a hurricane ♪
♪ It's Ed Sheeran
going down a drain ♪
♪ It's Donald Trump's hair
with a chicken's wing ♪
♪ It's a 69,
don't want to be profane ♪
♪ Man, I don't know
what it is at all ♪
♪ All I know is that
it ain't a basketball ♪
♪ Hey, Tariq,
let me ask you ♪
♪ What is this thing?
Do you have a clue? ♪
♪ Well, it's weird,
and it's round ♪
♪ And it's red,
and it's white ♪
♪ Kind of looks like a cookie,
I'm gonna take a bite ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
[ Applause continues ]
Switching gears.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys,
did you hear about this?
"Cruel Summer" just became
Taylor Swift's
10th number-one song.
Okay. Four years --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's great.
Love that song.
But four years
after it was released.
It came out four years ago,
the original, yeah.
It's pretty crazy.
Now, some other artists
are hoping to get their
old songs charting again.
Check out what some
of them had to say.
First, Ed Sheeran said...
Yeah.
Then Sugar Ray said...
And then Shaggy said...
And then, uh...
[ Laughter ]
...Right Said Fred said...
And then Shaggy said...
And then...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then,
the Foo Fighters said...
And finally Shaggy said...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
Wild, what's going on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, listen to this.
I read that using
an anti-aging skin cream
has become super popular
among gen Z
and that one of the top brands
is called Drunk Elephant.
To be honest, I've never even
heard of Drunk Elephant.
-Oh, it's the absolute best,
Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Steve, you use
Drunk Elephant skin cream?
Every day,
and it really works.
[ Laughter ]
Here.
Watch this.
I just rub on
some little squirts
of Drunk Elephant cream
all over my face.
-Yeah, uh-huh.
I-I understand.
Yeah, you do that
all over your face.
And then what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Voilá.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
I look amazing,
and I feel amazing.
-Yeah, it's incredible.
You look just like John Stamos.
Is there any downsides?
-It wears off really quick.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
All right, I see,
well, thank you, Steve.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
-Great job.
Steve Mandel.
Looks great.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-Hey, guys, I saw that Tinder
has a new feature
called Matchmaker,
which allows your family
and friends
to weigh in on your matches.
[ Laughter ]
There's already a name for that.
It's called Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
"Why aren't you married?"
I'm just not sure your date
wants to hear, "Great news.
Mother thinks
we're a perfect match."
[ "Psycho" music plays ]
[ Applause ]
I heard about a man in Florida
who was arrested for allegedly
using red and blue lights
on his car
and trying to pull vehicles over
while wearing
a Tampa Bay Buccaneers jersey.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like retirement's
been pretty rough for Tom Brady.
I think --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys, finally it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WePost ♪
♪♪
♪ WePost ♪
Welcome to "WePost."
This is where we
as a group decide something
we should post on socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts.
We're all going
to vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep. Hey, perfect.
Alright.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want,
I just want you to have fun,
have a good time here.
Higgins, Roots.
You have clickers, too?
-Got it.
Alright, I'll post
whichever one
gets the most
likes from all of us.
Because it's not a me post.
It's a we post.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, you ready?
Alright.
The first post is...
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, enjoy."
-"Enjoy."
-"Yeah.
Hey, you'll love it.
I did --
I mean, you will, you will."
-"Those are real good."
-Alright, the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Yeah.
Not bad -- 136.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright,
let's go to this next one.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Hmm. "Ooh!"
-"Ooh!"
-"Ooh, hi!"
-"Candelabras."
-"Ooh, fancy."
Alright, let's see
the results here.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
Do not be our guest.
-Alright, yeah.
-Wow.
-Very honest audience.
Yeah, they go, "No."
-Thank you, no.
-They could have
chose not to vote.
-Yeah, no.
-They chose to vote no.
No.
But I love that.
Alright, here we go.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, window units
are the above ground...
I'm afraid of those things.
-Yeah.
-I was afraid to -- I was afraid
to install those ones.
I was afraid they would
fall out the window.
Alright, let's see
the results right here.
Alright, not bad.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two below.
-I don't know.
I mean, these all -- they don't
necessarily get better.
I just want to remind you guys.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, this one says...
-They're like pointing
at things.
-Too small.
-"Oh, uh..."
Pointing at stuff.
Alright, let's see
the results here.
Come on.
-I like this one.
-Whoa! My God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Oh, wow.
-Wow.
-Now you're being too nice.
[ Laughter ]
Now you're being too nice.
-Gotta be be a record.
-[ Laughs ]
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] Hey, you know
where the screw--
[ Clears throat ]
You know where the wrenches are?
-Nope.
-You want to arm wrestle?
-[ Normal voice ] Alright,
let's see the results here.
No, we got it back.
There you go.
We have a winner.
It looks like it's this
right here.
There's always two people...
[ Bell dings ]
I'm going to post this
during the break.
If you happen to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.